this is something that I spend a lot of
time thinking about and I know why
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac which are the
subjects of this book are in our
important companies but why you start by
telling us a little bit about you know
why you wrote the book and why Fannie
and Freddie are so important to kind of
the broader populace okay so I started
covering Fannie back in 2004 when I was
still at fortune and in the wake of this
big accounting scandal each company had
had a big accounting scandal and at the
time I think I was shocked to find out
the companies like this existed I mean
what is a government-sponsored
enterprise and what a government inter
sponsored enterprise in this case is
Fannie was created back in the wake of
the depression by Roosevelt in order to
help make home ownership more widely
available and the idea was that if you
had this institution that could buy up
the loans that banks lenders had made
then that would free those lenders to go
out and make more loans because they
wouldn't have to worry that their
capital was all all tied up and the loan
they had made so the idea was this would
this would help foster home ownership
and that was the beginning of Fannie Mae
in this very unique system in the United
States no other country has it no other
country has a thirty-year fixed-rate
fully pre-payable mortgage either the
way we do and most people credit that to
the existence of Fannie and Freddie and
so these these two companies have grown
to be absolutely enormous Fannie and
Freddie together are the largest
financial institution in the world they
owner guarantee over five billion at
five trillion dollars of mortgage
related debt they're absolutely enormous
they're critical to the functioning of
the global financial system and they're
sort of part of the hidden machinery
that makes our lives possible you know
when you go to the bank and get your
mortgage you expect to have a mortgage
rate quoted to you right right right
then and there and for decades
Fannie in particular has been part of
what what has what has made that
function seamlessly sure yeah and so and
so I think in recent history a lot of
people know them as the you know one of
the first two companies to be taken over
by the government you know some people
say that they were at least partly
so go for the for the financial crisis
and and I mean a lot a lot of people
think that this is a problem that the
government fixed a long time ago right
like it wasn't this late isn't this like
a seven year old problem but but now
kind of here we are and I guess how how
far have we gotten
we haven't gotten anywhere that's that's
part of the problem so the idea was
there's the silver lining in the global
financial crisis right like I should
back up a little bit you're exactly
right they were the first two companies
that were that were I guess there was
Bear Stearns first but then fan-in
Fanning but was sort of bailed out by
JPMorgan a sort of private transaction
right Fannie and Freddie were put into
the state called conservatorship where
they were where they're supported by
line of credit from from from the
Treasury and effectively managed by a
government agency and when they were
taken over in the fall of 2008 the idea
was this would be temporary
conservatorship was supposed to be
temporary we were going to figure out
how to reform the housing finance system
and we can talk about why people think
it was problematic beforehand we are
going to reform them and and get on with
it and here we are seven years later
these two giant companies are still in
the state called conservatorship in this
big public policy question what do we
want housing finance to be like is still
totally unresolved I think that's an
issue for every American with a mortgage
it's an issue for every American who has
wealth tied up in a house it's an issue
for every investor because these five
trillion dollars of securities move
through the global financial system like
water they're everywhere if there's a
change in the value of these securities
or a lack of confidence in them that
will have global economic ripple effects
right so let's back up a little bit
because I think a lot of people don't
understand you know literally what the
function of a Fannie and Freddie are so
so I'm a homeowner I you know go to my
my bank or lender to get a mortgage and
the lender grants that to me so so what
what happens then and how is Fannie
involved yeah so that's what's known as
the primary market when you go to a
lender and you get your mortgage but
those lenders don't keep those mortgages
anymore at least they mostly don't keep
those mortgages they sell them off and
most of them in the air since the
financial crisis the great majority of
them get sold off to Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac who then take them packaged
them up and sell them off as securities
to investors around around the world and
the existence of this system and in
Fannie and Freddie act as an insurance
company they guarantee the timely
payment of on those on those mortgages
so the investor who buys them has to
worry that interest rates might change
right but they don't have to worry that
you the homeowner are going to be unable
to pay because Fannie and Freddie are
guaranteeing that so that system has
turned American mortgages into something
that buyers around the world can invest
in without without thinking twice
because they don't have to go through
and analyze a hundred thousand Joe
lights and make sure all of you are
really going to pay your mortgage they
can just buy these securities knowing or
feeling that they know that the
securities that the securities are safe
in the way that system has developed it
means that a saver in China can and does
finance the purchase of a home in Kansas
so it's turned I think it's ironic in a
way it's turned American homeownership
I mean what's more domestic than a home
right right into a global into a global
financial issue right and and this is
something that's unique to the United
States or at least to the United States
and you know maybe one or two other
countries so what is having this system
in place give Americans that you know
somebody and you know the United Kingdom
getting a home won't get so that's part
of a debate right there are some people
who say if you got rid of Fannie and
Freddie there would be no impact the
market would continue exactly as it is
and private capital would fulfill the
role that that Fannie and Freddie play I
want to pause on that point for for one
second the fact that Fannie and Freddie
are government-sponsored I think needs
to be explained what that means it's led
to this implicit perception in the years
before conservatorship that the US
government would stand behind Fannie and
Freddie meaning that a Fannie and
Freddie couldn't pay if you'd fault it
on your mortgage and Fannie and Freddie
somehow didn't have the money to pay the
US government would would step in and
pay and that's obviously what happened
since they were put into into into a
conservatorship
that system has given Americans access
to a 30-year fixed-rate mortgage which
is something that people around the
globe don't happen that 30-year
fixed-rate pre-payable mortgage is a
total fixture of American life right I
think I saw some data from the Urban
Institute that some 80 percent of buyers
who are buying a home are choosing a
30-year fixed-rate mortgage mm-hmm right
where's in other countries you'll have a
mortgage with a much shorter term with
interest rates that change more often
you might have you might have a 10-year
mortgage where the interest rate floats
around so you as a homeowner don't know
what your mortgage payment is going to
be every month because it moves this
interest rate moves so if interest rates
doubled from five to ten percent your
mortgage payments could double every
month right so the existence of Fannie
and Freddie has made a mortgage a stable
instrument at least for the homeowner
right so you talked a little bit about
the the government guarantee so having
the government in there and I guess
giving this in implicit you know
suggestion or whatever you want to call
it to investors that they're going to
step in a Fannie or Freddie couldn't
what what did that get homeowners before
the crisis so there's a good question
about what that got homeowners before
the crisis I think it got them the
argument was always it got them a lower
rate on their mortgages than they would
otherwise have the fact that Fannie and
Freddie had this imprimatur of the US
government standing behind them meant
that they could pass along lower
interest rates the lower cost on their
debt because it's perceived as safer so
it cost less to homeowners who could
then pay lower rates on their mortgage
than they might have to pay in a system
without without without Fannie and
Freddie and it certainly meant I think
this this this longer term this longer
term mortgage there was always a debate
in the years before the crisis well how
much of a benefit did that actually give
to homeowners in my view that debates a
little bit moot since the financial
crisis in the wake of the financial
crisis private capital completely fled
the mortgage market if we hadn't had
Fannie and Freddie there there would not
have been a mortgage market and arguably
the downturn that followed the financial
crisis would have been a lot worse so
Fannie and Freddie serve the purpose of
stepping in to provide to provide
mortgage credit when the private sector
won't do it right so you spent a lot of
time in the book kind of talking about
the rise of Fannie and Freddie after
development how they sort of accumulated
political influence in Washington he
can't can you talk a little bit about
you kind of how they did that and the
sort of you know the sort of opinions
and fears of Fannie and Freddie that
kind of came as a result yeah so ever
since Fannie and Freddie were created
there were always people in the
government in academia who said what
what are we doing with the government
presence in the housing market we're a
free market economy were a capitalist
economy what is a government-sponsored
enterprise
why can't private private capital just
take care of Americans mortgage needs
there was this just inherent sort of
ideological resistance to the idea of
Fannie and Freddie in response to that
Fannie and Freddie developed real
lobbying muscle I think it was former
congressman Jim leach who used to say
that Fannie had the most sophisticated
lobbying operation he'd ever seen in his
in his entire life and the reason they
did that is because they felt like there
were forces in the US government that
we're trying to kill them and you know
what they were they were right so they
developed this outsized aggression to
any threat to their existence or any
threat to take away their that the
advantages they had from this this
perception that the u.s. government
would would stand beside them and they
became a really formidable political
political force and I think that in some
ways intensified the resentment against
them you know you have people who found
themselves on the wrong side and again
this was led by Sam Danny primarily it's
always been kind of the bigger and more
aggressive and more powerful of the two
companies I think you had people who
ended up on the wrong side of Fanny and
felt that it really resented the company
for the way for them for the way it
behaved you had in the 1990s pannies
executives were real democratic power
players
Jim Johnson the Washington Post once
called him the chairman of the Universe
Frank Raines had been the head of OMB
under under
Bill Clinton previously had been in the
OMB and was there was talk could be the
first black president I mean they were
they were democratic power players and
they made a ton of money and so there
was a lot of resentment around that too
and I think there's always been in the
mortgage market is one of the biggest
markets in the world right
it's there's fights about money right
private companies banks even mortgage
insurers other players in the
homeownership market totally resented
Fannie and Freddie's profits because it
meant less for them right right and so
Fannie became part of this I like to
call it I'm not the first to use this
phrase that the housing industrial
complex this sort of loose-knit really
durable sometimes fractious debatably
unhealthy kind of alliance of everybody
who has a stake in this enormous
enterprise that is the American mortgage
market yeah yeah I love some of the
anecdotes you gave about kind of their
lobbying prowess in the book and why the
ones you mentioned if I remember right
there was a there's a nonprofit that was
offered a grant by by Fannie right and
then then what happened after that yeah
so ironically and we can compact why
this is ironic but one of the criticisms
in the 1990s one of Fannie and Freddie's
responsibilities that was given to them
by Congress is sort of quid pro quo for
these special advantages they had from
the perception they were close to the US
government was that they had to do
things for affordable housing and they
had specific quotas of loans they needed
to make that would satisfy these these
these affordable housing goals and
during the 1990s the constant cry from
both housing activists and ironically
from people on the right who didn't want
Fannie and Freddie to exist was they
don't do enough they're not doing
anything they're just all about their
own profits and they aren't doing
anything to make loans more more more
widely available so this housing
activist was criticizing them for for
doing that only to call up Fannie - he
was supposed to get his organization was
supposed to get a grant only to get a
call from a senior person at Fannie
saying sorry no more money we're not
we're not we're not going to give it to
you and he actually called Jim Johnson
and said said stand inside
you can't possibly be that small-minded
can you right yeah I remember I remember
a quote from the book says it's somebody
describing their lobbying prowess
there's something like you know they'll
they'll cut you up got you and throwing
the river it was a great or something
like it was a great quote from a
Washington Post piece in the 1990s and I
think it's another of the great ironies
because Fannie Mae sounds like the candy
company it sounds like a grandmother it
sounds so sweet and harmless her and in
reality it's this monstrous financial
empire that had at the time just
unparalleled political clout right yeah
and you probably got this from your
reporting too but it seems like part of
the resentment about how they acted is
how how much people felt that they
dependent on the government for existing
in the first place so so on the one hand
you're dependent on us for on our
guarantee for your very business model
and on the other hand you're spending
all this money you know threatening
people around you know around Washington
yeah cetera great quote in the book from
Larry Summers former Treasury secretary
and he says look if you were going to
design a scheme to extort money from the
US government you couldn't do it better
than then than this basically you know
have this hidden subsidy and what an
economist means by hidden subsidy was
there was this implicit guarantee this
idea that the US government would stand
behind Fannie and Freddie but it wasn't
explicit Fannie and Freddie didn't pay a
fee for it so it was kind of this free
money that Fannie and Freddie could then
turn around and exploit in order to pay
their executives really well and to have
huge lobbying muscle right so how do we
know that that that implicit guarantee
was going to homeowners as opposed to
the the profits of Fannie and Freddie I
think there's a big argument that it
wasn't there were a lot of studies done
in the 1990s that said most of the
benefit from it was flowing through to
the executives and to shareholders of
Fannie and Freddie
not to homeowners and most Fannie used
to argue it was a small amount it was
like 25 basis points which is a quarter
of a percent so if you say if your
monthly mortgage mortgage payments you
know were 100 dollars it would reduce it
a little bit if if Fannie if Annie's
math was right I think that's a good
interesting debate but I think it's sort
of irrelevant
in the context of what happened in 2008
because the value of Fannie and Freddie
is that they're there when the private
market isn't we don't we may not need
them in good times but we certainly need
them in bad times so to say in this
giant boom decade of the 1990s that
Fannie and Freddie weren't providing
much value and then to ignore what
happened in the fall of 2008 when
private capital completely deserted the
market seems to me like a funny way to
look at the issue
yeah and although in the 90s like
politically that did build a lot of
resentment among people there's a lot of
people who were kind of looking for that
chance to absent it totally helped feed
the resentment of Fannie and Freddie
what do they do anyway why do we need
these companies right and there was
always these cause chorus of people who
said they're gonna there they're too big
to fail we're going to land on taxpayers
with a giant thud and which is exactly
what happened even if it wasn't
precisely for the reasons that were that
were that people were predicting
President Obama only a few years ago
described it as heads we win tails you
lose a mentality ISM so it was you know
this idea that no matter what happened
Fannie and Freddie would win because in
good times that pay their executives and
in bad times that get bailed out by
taxpayers right and you feel a lot of
that even today I mean what one of the
Congress can't pass anything it seems
like and then just just a few days ago
one of the things at the Senate
universally agreed on was to put a new
cap on the the pay of Fannie and Freddie
CEOs it seems like it's very fashionable
to dislike these companies you know even
even today oh it has become I think
extremely fashionable it dislike these
companies after the financial crisis
which is ironic because without them I
think the government dependence on the
dependent the mortgage markets
dependence on Fannie and Freddie has
never been more than in the years since
the financial crisis right so you would
think that would have given them some
sort of mojo but the hatred of them is
intensified and I think there's a
there's a clear reason for that this
narrative took hold and is very popular
in a lot of circles that Fannie and
Freddie and these goals they had to make
housing affordable we're solely
responsible for the financial
this is it's kind of akin to a religious
war in many ways because if you can say
that Fannie and Freddie and the
government were solely responsible for
the financial crisis well then there was
no problem in the private sector and the
private sector doesn't need any more
rate regulation the only answer is get
rid of the government and we'll all be
we'll all be just fine and it as a
result of that narrative even Fannie and
Freddie's once staunch supporters have
have run from them Barney Frank was the
congressman sort of most closely
associated with Fannie and Freddie in
the 1990s as a defender of theirs and
even he said they should be abolished
right and it seems like in none of the
issues is that this isn't their first
scandal right there was a there's an
interim scandal that's easy to forget
even though it was easy for to forget
because of the financial crisis even
though it was less than less than 20
years ago so what would and this
happened in the early 2000s or what did
they go through so this was my first
exposure to Fannie and Freddie was these
accounting scandals back in the mid
2000s that led to the ouster of all of
the senior management teams of both both
companies and they were slightly
different the idea was that Freddie was
actually understating earnings and the
idea that was that Fannie was
manipulating a really a complicated
accounting statute about how you account
for it for derivatives and overstating
its earnings and it was a huge scandal
Fannie's management team was kicked out
the company had to do this mammoth
Restatement of earnings their regulator
even called Fannie Mae a
government-sponsored Enron and just
pause to think of how about how odd that
is can you imagine say Citigroup's
regulator saying that Citigroup is a
government-sponsored Enron I mean that's
a that's what those are big words right
the really strange thing and someone
said to me that the story of the GSE is
like a mixture of Monty Python and
Shakespeare and it has all these like
strange twists and turns the really odd
thing about that accounting scandal is
that when Fanny actually a now released
its Restatement of earnings its
shareholders equity went up not down
most important measure of a company
strength went way up and despite all
this rhetoric about how franklin raines
was a was a fraudster never charged by
the Justice Department never charged by
the SE
see the judge ended up throwing out the
civil claims against him saying that
against him and Tim Howard saying there
was absolutely no evidence that that
either man did anything wrong so it's a
very you would expect when a regulator
calls a company a government-sponsored
entrant and Enron that this is going to
end with a bang right people in jail and
it ended with such a weird little
whimper yes I mean why why do you think
the government kind of overplayed I
overplayed their hand there I think it
was deep-seated fear and anger against
Fannie and Freddie this real sense that
they were abusing the position they were
in that they were lining their
executives pockets that they were a huge
danger to the financial system and they
needed to be reined in and Fannie in
particular successfully fought every
attempt to rein it in by muscling it's
it's it's political clout and I think I
think people who were very well
intentioned started to feel intensely
friends frustrated at their inability to
rein in Fannie and Freddie and their
real sense that these two companies were
a systemic were a systemic risk and I
think the fight became very ugly on both
sides the unfortunate thing about it is
that after the management teams of both
companies were ousted just at the
beginning of the most dangerous bubble
in American real estate in history
Congress was still unable to pass any
new legislation raining in Fannie and
Freddie great and I want to pause on
that for one reason because I think it's
it's really popular to say that Fannie
and Freddie are democratic problem you
know the Republicans are righteous on
this issue and and Fannie and Freddie
are the Democrats problem but we had a
Republican in charge of the white house
and a Republican Congress and they were
still unable to pass any any legislation
it helps explain where we aren't now but
you know as well as I do
Republicans are as reluctant to to sort
of disrupt this issue as as some
Democrats are right I mean we had to
start this conversation talking about
what these companies do you know this is
not right it's not something you're
going you can fit into a stump speech
very easily unless you're going to give
the very blanket you know let's just not
yell she's good I get rid of them so
let's talk a little bit about the
the about the housing boom and I guess
what Fannie and Freddie's participation
that really was I mean started to say
that they didn't they didn't really go
you know go as far out as some of the
other private lenders but what were
feeding Freddie doing during this period
Fannie and Freddie definitely
contributed to the tip to the bubble and
their need to satisfy these affordable
housing goals definitely contributed to
the problem I just don't think it's the
sole cause of the financial crisis by
the mid-2000s Fannie and Freddie's
market share had been cut in half as
this sort of subprime lending where
instead of mortgage originators selling
their mortgages to Fannie and Freddie
they were selling them to Wall Street
firms and totally bypassing Fannie and
Freddie cutting them out of the market
and that's what all the haters of Fannie
and Freddie wanted to see happen right
have Fannie and Freddie cut out of the
market the problem was the standards for
these loans were getting riskier and
riskier and riskier so around 2005 both
Fannie Fannie and Freddie did two things
they started buying some of these Wall
Street securities for their own own
portfolios and using them to to meet the
meet their affordable housing goals and
they decided we need to get into this
business too and you can trace that
through market share numbers through
interviews with executives through
executive presentations they were
terrified that they were losing they
were losing their profits losing their
hold on the market so they began to make
riskier to guarantee riskier loans - you
can see by the numbers that the loans
they guaranteed were never as risky as
the private sector loans that that
helped bring down the system the default
rate on comparable GSE backed loans
versus wall street loans like a fraction
of the default rate but nonetheless it
totally contributed to the crisis and it
was enough to create the perception that
Fannie and Freddie needed a bailout
right so I mean one of the things that
the people also allege in the run-up to
the crisis is that is that it was not
only Fannie and Freddie who decided to
take on more risk but that these
affordable housing goals and the
government were trying to get them to
take on more risk through research where
do you come down on that I think it was
some of both I think it was I think they
did the companies did some of what they
did
to spy affordable housing goals but they
did a lot of what they did in order to
increase their market share and keep and
produced profits and you can see that
through executive presentations at the
time how do we keep up with the market
how do we keep our profits we need to be
relevant so it's you can't be simplistic
about it you know you can't say it was
one thing or the other it was it was
both it was a mixture of reasons it was
a mixture of reasons why they why they
did it whose job was it to make sure
that that that didn't get out of hand
right well Fannie and Freddie were
overseeing they were regulated they have
had a government agency called the
office of Federal Housing Enterprise
oversight whose only job was to regulate
Fannie and Freddie and to the regulator
knew that they were going into riskier
loans and didn't think twice about it
and didn't didn't Randy was it a
staffing issue or woods that a political
we should get the confidence issue in
some ways I think it's I think there was
this a competence issue and I say that
not meaning to categorically say people
were incompetent there was this idea
that the private sector knew what it was
doing right that if if lenders were
making these loans and if Wall Street
firms were buying them up and if
investors were buying the securities
well then everybody knew what they were
doing and everybody was analyzing the
risk and making sure the people could
pay could pay their loans back and I
think no one realized it sounds crazy
but no one realized until it all went to
hell in a handbasket that no actually no
one was doing that work and in fact
people couldn't pay those loans back
right and kind of part and parcel of
that in addition to making Riccar
riskier loans you had Fannie and Freddie
start to invest in some of those
securities that the private market was
playing but anything that's it's the
biggest irony and one of the most sort
of twisted tragic parts of this story
that one of the things that brought
Fannie and Freddie down that created all
the losses that that led to the
perception that they needed a bailout
they started to buy the wall street
manufactured securities and pulled them
on their on their on their own balance
sheet and so when those securities
started to lose value Fannie and Freddie
had to take huge losses on them and and
what they were doing buying loans that
had already been packaged up and sold
off to investors by Wall Street and then
that
to be one of the more screwed up things
and kind of college and they were trying
to satisfy their Wall Street pact those
those products with with loans that
satisfied Fannie and Freddie's housing
goals so they were trying to satisfy
their their house their housing goals
too right so yeah I want to pause on
this issue of the housing goals and the
crisis because I think there's this
there's this really widespread
misperception that I think is actually
kind of worse among people who who
understand the issue because it's almost
intellectually dishonest that putting
people who couldn't afford homes into
homes is what caused the crisis and we
should never do that again
it was not the majority of risky loans
that were packaged up and turned into
securities were not made for the
purposes of homeownership
they were made for refinancings usually
cash out refinancings whereby somebody
takes out a bigger mortgage takes the
cash uses it to pay off bills pay down
other debt maybe go on vacation maybe
remodel their house but if you if you
hadn't made those loans and you hadn't
done all the crazy investment loans
where people were buying you know seven
or eight properties and trying to get
rich there would not have been a
financial crisis so the crisis has
become this referendum on homeownership
you know this it's as if it proves this
idea we should never extend credit to
people who might be on the margins of
being qualified for homeownership
because look what happened in the
financial crisis it just it's not a
referendum on that one that one way or
the other
yeah there's been academic work done
showing that the majority of defaults in
the financial crisis were actually from
quite affluent borrowers who didn't who
didn't who didn't pay their refinancings
their cash out refinancing so it's a
referendum on extending credit to people
who can't afford to pay it back and on
the sort of rampant crazy extension of
credit to borrowers at every income
level but it's not a referendum on
homeownership
yes interesting because they've been
entire books written you know even even
once I've come out recently you know
that that they kind of blame Fannie and
Freddie in the affordable housing goal
for the crisis so so is why did this why
did this become a cause celeb for I
think it's I think it's a really clear
way to one it makes people like to
simplify complex issues right and even
if it's only the illusion of clarity it
feels good it feels like clarity and I
think if you can say the
government caused the financial crisis
you you've got a really clear simple
explanation right you don't have to say
oh my god it was all these complicated
factors you can just reduce it to to
this one simple thing and I think that's
part of its appeal I think the other
part of the appeal is in anti-regulation
appeal if you can say that Fannie and
Freddie and the government did all this
then you can say well we don't need any
more regulation for Wall Street don't
get me wrong I'm not a believer in
regulation as the cure to all problems
so I don't mean to sound Pro regulation
I'm actually quite mixed on that point
but um but um you can you can get rich
you could get rid of dodd-frank right if
if the whole problem was Fannie and
Freddie then you don't need Todd Frank
throw it all out right right
so I think and then on top of that you
can of course get rid of Fannie and
Freddie and never have the government in
the housing market again because look
what it led to right so I think it's
this very very appealing argument and
it's gained an enormous amount of
currency despite the fact that I just
think it's readily disprovable if you
spend a little bit of time thinking
about it right so there's a 2008 you
know when everything started to go
downhill is when did it start to become
apparent that there were serious
problems that Fannie and Freddie and
then what why is what what would have
happened had the government not stepped
in really the last one I'm not sure I
can answer but this so this sort of
directly relates to this idea that
Fannie and Freddie caused the financial
crisis because the notion is that these
you know that fear about these loans
that were backed by Fannie and Freddie
started tremors in the global financial
system and that then spread to private
market loans and that's what brought
down the whole system just categorically
not true Fannie and Freddie stock prices
were at all-time highs and the first
real tremor was when a French money
market fund couldn't pay because of
losses on US subprime mortgages which
were purely Wall Street mortgage-backed
securities nothing to do with Fannie and
Freddie and then this giant lender
called new century that was one of the
big subprime lenders was bankrupt in the
spring of 2007 before there were even
tremors at Bette Fannie and Freddie but
as the year went on the financial crisis
was was so odds wasn't one big
conflagration right there kept being
this eruption and then things would calm
down a little and then there would be
another eruption and as the year 2008
went on people got increasingly worried
about Fannie and Freddie because you
could see that they had a lot of riskier
mortgages on their books and you know if
you've got a giant housing downturn
going on you have two highly leveraged
institutions whose sole business is
taking the credit risk of US homeowners
they're going to have a problem right
and I think arguably they could have had
there could have been a huge loss of
confidence in them even if they had
ventured into buying into guaranteeing
these these riskier mortgages so by the
summer of 2008 their stock prices were
plummeting and there was great fear that
they wouldn't be able to wouldn't be
able to raise money in the markets and
the whole machine would grind to a halt
and I think it's fascinating because we
generally think of globalization is this
good thing right well not always but
Hank Paulson who was Treasury secretary
tells this great story about being in
Beijing for the Summer Olympics then
hearing a story that the Russians were
trying to get the Chinese to dump their
holdings of Fannie and Freddie back
securities in order to create chaos and
the global global and the global economy
and then there's this Chinese financial
official telling Bloomberg that you know
if the US government lets Fannie and
Freddie to to fail it's going to be the
end of the global financial system as we
know it right so there was this idea
that if these two companies were to go
down their securities were everywhere it
would disrupt foreign central banks
foreign global relations it would just
wreak havoc through all the banks that
held these securities on their own
balance sheets it would shut down the
mortgage market so there was this
perception that we couldn't we couldn't
let these two these two companies fail
right yeah it's interesting because
having so much interconnectedness and
the more MBS having such a large market
even even if you're not sure of what the
probabilities are that Fame and fray are
going to fail if the consequences are so
dire that you have an outcome like what
the Ang's were saying they could take it
you'd rather you'd rather act right and
and be wrong than
roll the dice there's a huge sort of
subterranean fight over whether Fannie
and Freddie really needed a bailout and
I tend to cut the government a little
bit of slack for what it did in the 2008
financial crisis look it was a financial
crisis I mean it's easy to look back now
and say oh people could have done things
differently maybe this company didn't
need a bailout maybe we could have let
them fail
you know hindsight really is 28 2020 and
so I tend to think that arguments about
what happened in that in 2008 are a
little beside the point so right
although there there are arguments which
is why I caveat what I say sure sure but
it but and yet the way they put them
into conservatorship and it was the
genesis of why things are still so
screwed up right now this house I guess
that talk a little bit about why why
they use this process called
conservatorship and you know the sort of
structures they set up around that so
conservatorship is actually a really
well-known thing it's how the FDIC saves
a failing bank it's it's and the the
laws governing Fannie and Freddie's
conservatorship are basically lifted
straight from the FDIC and how they how
they rehabilitate a failing bank so it
wasn't like the idea of conservatorship
was anything new there are a couple that
said they're a couple really weird
things about Fannie and Freddie's
conservatorship right one is that the
terms of their bailout were so much
tougher than the bailouts of the big
banks and the and the bailout of AIG you
know AIG is back to back back to semi
normal but back to being a publicly
traded company right the big banks I
mean their executives didn't even get
fired they're back to paying their
shareholders and executives you know
tens of millions of dollars in bonuses
Fannie and Freddie uniquely
conservatorship has become a kind of
prison a limbo from which it seems like
they will never be released and there's
been some argument by former FDIC people
that look this is not what
conservatorship is conservatorship is
rehabilitate put companies on a sound
financial footing and put them back out
there it's not kind of a license to
steal the profits of these companies
forever yes interesting because I mean
the FDIC has its conservatorship law and
then for the conservatorship of Fannie
and Freddie a whole separate law call
called Hera what was past it kind of
create these different structures and
sort of people people thought they are
familiar with the concept of
conservatorship to the FDIC and a lot of
times the FDIC a used conservatorship
it's kind of a stopping point to
receivership which is obviously not what
the government want to do with Fannie
Freddie but when the government bailed
out Fannie and Freddie is not like they
they took away all of the publicly
traded shares right they unless some of
those out there so what exactly did they
leave behind when the government came in
yeah so it's so it's another I think
it's kind of a game of let's pretend
right the government left them 20% of
the common of the securities of Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac outstanding in the
hands of private shareholders these were
never supposed to have any value because
the government was taking a huge ten
percent dividend any money that the
government injected into Fannie and
Freddie that get paid 10 percent on
their money huge huge ownerís dividend
and then the government took seventy
nine point nine percent of the equity of
both companies so what was left if these
two companies were going to you know
lose money from here until eternity was
nothing so shareholders were supposed to
be wiped out even though there was this
this this stump basically uh that was
left trading but at the time the
government did it the government said
well you know what the lot regulator
Fannie and Freddie's even said you know
what this this might have value someday
right and do you think they said they
said that it meant it or they or they
said that but I don't care if they said
it and mint or not they said it and so I
think and and they left the stock
outstanding so even though now they may
wish they didn't and I've heard
arguments from people in the government
that we only did that because we had to
because we didn't want to put Fannie and
Freddie's debt on the US balance sheet
so you shareholders you should know that
actually you were wiped out even if
that's not what we said at the time you
should just know better right and in for
and for a period of time after after the
conservatorship the shares traded like
they were wiped out right I mean it's
still traded but they were their pinches
pennies pennies
total pennies exactly but then what
happened is that some investors I
started to do the work and they
that oh all these losses that Fannie and
Freddie are are taking there's this
headline number that Fannie and Freddie
have taken 187 billion dollars in
taxpayer money to to bail them out but I
think isn't widely understood as if
that's sort of a made-up number Fannie
and Freddie had to take money based on
an accounting concept a kind of
complicated accounting concept called
net net worth and net worth means if
you're if you're if your assets are
worth less than your liabilities and
it's below zero then you have to draw
money to fill the hole and this concept
of net worth takes into account not only
today's losses but it says oh if you're
going to lose money on this loan in the
future that's going to reduce your net
worth today
- and so Fannie and Freddie took a lot
of money based on losses that were
supposedly coming in the future but that
actually never materialized
and so in truth the companies didn't
actually lose that much money on a on a
cash basis but they had to draw this
money anyway and so some investors began
to do the work and they said oh these
companies at some point they're going to
have to reverse all these losses they're
taking they're going to be really
profitable and what do we do in America
with companies that have gotten into
trouble well we restructure them you
know we figure out what makes sense and
we salvage them and we restructure them
so hey this is this is a great bed right
and then what happened and then the US
government in the summer of 2012 for
reasons that remain the subject of great
debate and controversy said oh we're
going to take instead of just having you
pay us a 10% dividend on whatever money
we've put into your Fannie and Freddie
we're going to take every pain every
penny of profits you make from now until
eternity right so I mean that the
government does give an explanation for
why they did that right I mean they they
argue I mean I you can describe that
yeah you could - but they argue that
that Fannie and Freddie we're going to
keep losing money and that and that they
all thought Fannie and Freddie we're
going to keep losing money they didn't
see that the companies were about to
become profitable and that it would be
two owners a requirement to pay this ten
percent dividend so instead they'd just
take everything that they happen to make
so if they made money in one quarter
than take it if they lost money in
another quarter obviously they'd get
money instead of having to insure it's a
little bit if you let me money and I was
supposed to pay you a dollar and
interest
every every every month and I couldn't
pay and so you said you know what
Bethenny I I won't take the dollar if
you don't have it but when you do have
some money I'm going to take it all
right and I guess part of the my
understanding is part of the reason they
say that they structured it that they
were especially worried about this it
kind of comes back to the
interconnectedness idea that were
talking about before so they have a it's
a at least for a certain period of time
it wasn't as if Fannie and Freddie had
an infinite amount of money to draw from
the government on so the extent that
that what they have left starts to get
smaller you start having you know
investors and mortgage-backed securities
in China or whatever thinking do I have
to start worrying about this right it's
one of the downsides again of this
global connected system we have right
the ostensible reason was well we don't
want the foreign central bank of China
to be worried that that that that Fannie
and Freddie don't have enough capital we
want to make sure that their securities
are safe and protected so this makes the
security seem safer than having this
requirement to pay a dividend with money
they may not have right Susie already
mentioned that and then in 2012 the
housing market was already it was
starting showing signs of a bottom and
starting to get better again do I guess
what do you so we know what the
government said was the reason they did
it what do you think was the reason that
they get it you know I don't this is
still it's the subject of these mammoth
lawsuits right that are wending their
way through court and there could be
things that come out on both sides that
are that are really interesting I almost
hope this goes to trial because I think
it'll be sort of fascinating insight
into the workings of the government as
well as Fannie and Freddie but it is
hard to see that the government didn't
understand that the two companies were
about to become really profitable they
had investors in there telling them that
and there's been some interesting stuff
that has come out in the court cases
testimony from a former Fannie financial
person saying they knew they knew we're
about to become really profitable so
that that's strange right I guess I'm in
the camp of if the government had a good
reason for doing this I would like to
know what it was but the reason they've
given doesn't
to make sense and that makes me very
nervous because I don't like feeling
that we as taxpayers and citizens are
being lied to and that there was
something else going on and we don't
know what it what it was because the
apparent reason you've given just does
not seem to quite make sense I'm not
saying it doesn't you know I've got this
rule after two decades of covering
business that you should never
underestimate the amount of in
confidence in the world and it's
possible that everyone on Wall Street
understood these companies we're going
to start making enormous amounts of
money and the government actually just
just didn't I guess that's always
possible it's just it's somewhat hard to
believe yeah and in through my reporting
I mean sometimes it's felt like you've
got to remember that these are huge
organizations right and sometimes the
the right people the right people don't
know you know it's but you know it is it
is it is possible it is so it is totally
possible it just feels so at odds with
what actually happened given the
enormity of the profits that have come
from Fannie and Freddie in the last
couple of years they paid two hundred
and forty-one billion dollars to the US
Treasury right so it's not like oh they
squeaked out a few pennies here and
there in the US government didn't know
this was going to happen I mean this is
good two hundred forty 1 billion dollars
of profit so judges I can finish
connecting the dots there so you think
you think that maybe the reason they
started sweeping all the profits kind of
sent us back to the where we talk about
the 90s and early 2000s these are these
are companies that people were afraid of
and you think that it sounds like you
think maybe this was their opportunity
to I don't know I think I don't know
so I and it could be that the
government's explanation is absolutely
is absolutely true I just the facts
don't quite line up with it so that
makes me a little bit nervous there's
plenty of speculation that came out
through my reporting of other reasons
they might have done it one was you know
if these companies become incredibly
profitable again they're going to be
there's going to be pressure on us to
pop them back to life just as they were
and these companies were the worst thing
ever
how could how could we do that I think
there's speculation and it's certainly
true that they've been used as a tool to
reduce the federal budget deficit so
their speculation that the government
wanted those billions for its own
purposes rather than having
and Freddie keep keep the billions of
dollars that they were making in that
that could be possibly part of it and I
think some of the emails and
presentations that have come out in some
of the court cases suggest also that in
this kind of environment of not wanting
to see wealthy investors get paid even
though those wealthy investors actually
happen to manage the money of pension
funds and others but there's still this
kind of anti hedge fund we don't want to
see the investors get rich and I think
there was a feeling was explicitly
written we don't want in dusters to have
a payday sure yeah and so you just start
to talk about about what we're talking
about the hedge funds that we see on TV
all the time right like we're talking
about Paulson and company we're talking
about Bill Ackman and Pershing Square
we're talking about he's not a hedge
fund manager but mutual fund manager
Bruce Berkowitz which is a very popular
retail fund I mean a lot of a lot of
people on the Fairholme fund set name of
it name of his firm so so you mentioned
the ones that bought before the sweep
but but some of these funds also I mean
they analyzed the legal case and ended
up picking up shares after they started
sweeping the profits right and you have
a little less I guess sort of intrinsic
sympathy for that right because the ones
who bought before that before the
government changed its mind how are you
possibly to know afterwards what people
what people say though and I think it's
actually a very fair point is that look
this is wrong you can't do this this is
America this is not the way our system
is supposed to work Bruce Berkowitz has
this great line in the book you know
it's like I took 80% of your house in
the financial crisis and then you came
back and started paying and you were
making your mortgage payments and I said
no I'm going to take a hundred percent
right and it it feels wrong
there's another great line that I love
in the book that came from a former GSE
executive and this person said well it
feels anti-american then again they're
people who would argue that the GSEs
were always anti-american sure and do
you feel like the involvement of the of
the hedge funds has kind of complicated
this issue is how it can be solved
politically I think it is definitely
complicated the issue I think it's a
good thing I would argue it's a good
thing for a couple of reasons but I
think it has complicated the issue
because it's meant that you have these
very powerful I mean some of the most
powerful wealthiest people and funds in
the
nation sort of in their suing the US
government fighting for an outcome that
is not with what the administration has
said that it wants you know the
investors have very much come to push
for not just we want to get paid but we
want Fannie and Freddie back and that's
precisely what the administration has
said it does not want you know President
Obama has been pretty clear we do not
want Fannie and Freddie they've got to
go
so that's it's certainly complicated
matters I argue it's a good thing for a
couple of reasons
one is I don't think we want the
government to have a free hand you know
to make decisions behind closed doors
this is an issue that affects every
American in some way or another it
affects the interest rate you pay on
your mortgage it affects the
availability of mortgage credit it
affects the value of your house I don't
know that we want our government just
making a decision behind a closed door
that will affect everybody without some
sort of public debate about it and
that's one of the big reasons I I wrote
this book I also think that what
happened in 2012 maybe the government
was completely aboveboard and everything
they did was perfectly right but don't
you want to know I mean isn't it good to
have transparency and who else but a
wealthy investor can afford to sue the
US government and say no no let's look
at this let's make sure that what you
did was was was aboveboard I'm always a
believer in more transparency more
answers let's actually see what happened
and so so I've come to believe that the
investors while they are certainly after
their own payday are also sort of
raising awareness of this situation in a
way that I think is probably good right
well one of the great frustrations of
the court cases so far is that they're
going they're going through this
discovery process but the what they have
discovered isn't available to the the
public at least yet it's not even
available to the to the hedge funds that
the people who work here themselves is
available to the lawyers and people who
are underneath this protective or super
annoying right wouldn't you love to see
that stuff yeah and also a the
plaintiffs appeared I mean as plaintiffs
attorneys do appear to be very confident
in their filings and asserting that the
government lied but the every filing
it'll go something like you know it will
go something like you know such-and-such
government official said
but because of and then a big redacted
passage you know that's clearly not the
case and and you know and and and and
and as you as you said Koretz right yeah
and as you said it's almost a oh if all
you've got is a plaintiff's attorney if
you're on the government site and all
you guys a plainness attorney
characterizing these documents basically
the worst reflection of those documents
this come is coming out there right but
but a judge I mean a judge just recently
decided that at least for the time being
you know these documents are gonna are
great all right I can be made public
right so so one of the and this came up
in another talk he gave just a couple a
couple days ago so some of the hedge
funds which you know don't want this
litigation to go all the way you know to
the Supreme Court or wherever it ends up
their investment return to be more
positive it ends more quickly and
they're hoping the government will
decide to settle right and and one of
the ideas is that if we can get that
make this discovery public then there
it'll be so embarrassing that it or or
the threat of it becoming public will be
so embarrassing that they can move
toward a settlement what do you think of
that strategy well I don't like that as
an answer because I want transparency I
actually want to know what the
government was thinking when they did
the third amendment and when they
decided to take all the GSA's profits so
I don't like the idea of possible
government misbehavior being squelched
or covered just so the investors can
have a settlement right and I just I
feel like that's kind of its kind of
anti anti transparency that said one of
my fears about where we are today is
that there will be an external shock
like a victory in the law in the
lawsuits for it for the hedge funds or
like a incredibly embarrassing document
that the government doesn't want to
become public so they will they will
settle with investors or there'll be
some sort of shock that will force
Fannie and Freddie to go back to
Treasury and and take and and and take
more money and then they'll become a
huge political football again and so
instead of making a well thought-out
decision about what the structure of the
mortgage market could look like again an
issue that matters to every American
we're going to lurch into some sort of
you know half-baked
half-baked answer in order to avoid
discovery in order to avoid the
political brouhaha for another loss at
these two companies and I think that's
that's a really frightening prospect
right so so the Obama administration has
been adamant for a long time that they
want to see Congress solve this or that
they in Congress us all this are we are
we getting anywhere with that idea well
the Obama administration has been a
little more pointed than that I think
and you know this issue too so correct
me if I'm wrong but they've been pretty
clear they want Fannie and Freddie gone
so Obama even said in a speech in
Phoenix a couple of years ago it was you
know heads you win tails I lose
it's you know it gets wrong on these two
companies have gotta go so they've
they've been insistent that they want
private capital to finance the the
American mortgage market so we've got
this kind of disconnect going on and
tell me if you sense the same thing but
I think there's this pretty widespread
acceptance that if it were not for some
sort of government backstop in the
housing market this fixture of American
life the 30-year fixed-rate pre-payable
mortgage wouldn't wouldn't be there and
it certainly wouldn't be there for most
of the population in all economic times
it might be there for the very wealthy
might be there for more people when
economic times were very good but it
wouldn't be this fixture of American
life as as we know it so I think there
is actually an acceptance that we don't
want to pull the plug on some government
presence in the housing market yet
there's this anti Fannie Freddie
rhetoric and so it's kind of a stalemate
of what do we do so the most serious
reform was Crapo Johnson corker Warner
bill that that was wasn't the spring of
2014 it seems a long time ago no it does
it does but you know there's an argument
that that bill sort of recreated Fannie
and Freddie I mean it was a different
structure but you still had a government
backstop in in the housing market so if
you're still going to have a government
backstop sort of better the devil you
know why not reform Fannie and Freddie
and give them better regulation make
sure that they're there in sin
are not to produce extraordinary profits
for their shareholders and executives
but rather to run the businesses safely
structure them differently maybe even
toss in some counter cyclical measures
so if the mortgage market is going in
saying Fannie and Freddie pull back from
the mortgage market but why wouldn't you
use what try to fix what you have
instead of starting from scratch with a
totally untested system that is going to
support the most important asset in most
Americans lives right so so sorry is
what what do you feel like should be
happening right now then I you know I'm
somewhat I'm somewhat torn on this
there's a part of me that has always
disliked the cult of homeownership even
though it has been part of our society
from from from from the beginning I felt
like we needed to do a larger rethink of
both this notion and of of the how we
financed homeownership and a larger
rethink down to you know if you're doing
a cash out refinancing should that be
treated just like if you're buying a
home you know if we're encouraging
homeownership why are we also
encouraging people to treat their home
as a credit card those are two
antithetical things they're not just
different they're antithetical so why
does our system of laws and tax laws and
mortgage credit enable both equally
shouldn't we do this this larger rethink
I'm not sure we're going to do that and
so I've started to believe I'd rather
see a reformed Fannie and Freddie with
much tighter regulation much limits on
what their executives can make maybe
structured like a utility right with an
acceptable rate of return rather than a
kind of swing for the fences make
whatever you can and get rich structure
you know it's a sort of I've used this
this line but it's like Winston
Churchill's favorite famous line about
democracy right Fannie and Freddie are
kind of the worst possible system until
you start to consider all the
alternatives